first two but some of that depends on
questions and everything else so this is
a very different way for understanding
matrix Rademacher series that was
developed in a paper called matrix
concentration and equalities via the
method of exchangeable pairs which was
written with Westar Mackay Mike Jordan
two of my group
Richard Chen Brendan Farrell and me okay
so the principle that I traced back to
the work of all's meta in winter is
their idea that you can take methods for
proving scalar concentration and
equalities and look those arguments to
the matrix setting scale argument
capitalize things and with silver mount
of effort you can repeat the argument
for matrices and get a matrix equivalent
okay now there's a beautiful approach to
rent to scaler concentration due to
Suraj Chatterjee this Ennis thesis and
there's a paper from 2008 where he uses
the method of exchangeable payers due to
charles Stein from 1972 to establish
some concentration inequalities for
scalar random variables so this is maybe
not so familiar so I'm not going to go
through the scalar version of the
argument but I'll spend a bit of time on
the details so you can see how this
works because it turns out that this
argument lists two matrices without any
fancy equipment like leaves theorem and
leads to some extraordinarily simple
proofs of some very deep result
so we're gonna use a matrix version of
this idea to prove something called the
matrix khinchin inequality
I'll tell you what that is in just a
minute but it's a moment in equality for
Rademacher theory Rademacher series okay
so here's the result so there are a lot
of names attached to this OC this is due
to fronts wazoo speak are from 1986
there was further work with the GOP za
in 1991 there's a paper by Archer
Buchholz in 2002 and so these are all
different versions of this all right so
what's the setting we've got some fixed
hermitian matrices and we've got some
Rademacher random variables epsilon 1 up
to epsilon n is are iid and we're
interested once again in the matrix
series obtained by modulating these
matrices a K by Ronna mockers and adding
them up ok so the result is that if
you're interested in computing trace
moments of this random matrix there's a
bound
so the two-piece trace moment is bounded
by root 2 P minus 1 times the
expectation of the trace of X sorry in
the wrong place this is the trace of the
expectation of x squared to the P power
to the 1 over 2 P for P equals 1 to 3
and so forth so the bound under prove is
just for integers this leading constant
here is within a factor of root II of
Sharpe
so this is about as good as this kind of
result gets and remember this guy here
is the sum of the a K squared just like
in the last lecture all right so what
does this result tell us it says that
the trace moments of this Rademacher
series grow like the moments of a
standard normal variable so remember
these are roughly 2p to the P same here
it's it's true for the constant changes
a little bit maybe but this is a known
to be true for all P greater than or
equal to one I'm just proving it for the
integers because it's a little easier
okay so for those in the real analysis
program this is what you might call a
hyper contractive inequality for
matrices okay so it just says at the
moments decay really fit moments don't
grow too fast and if you're interested
in controlling the spectral norm you can
use the fact that the trace a to the P
to the one over P is roughly equal to
the spectral norm of a if P is equal to
the roughly equal to the log of the
dimension of the matrix a so these
powers trace powers are not so different
from the spectral norm for large enough
powers okay so this allows you to get
bounced on spectral norms as well do
lots of other stuff so the reason this
result is powerful is because you can
combine it with symmetrization arguments
so we're not going to get into this but
you can replace 0 mean random variables
in some case by the same variable
multiplied by a Rademacher variable and
then compute conditional bounds by
averaging over the rata mockers so you
can do lots and lots of stuff using this
kind of technique all right any
questions on the statement of this
result we were going to prove it all of
us together
okay by the way you can extend this to
rectangular matrices just like we did in
the last hour so this is actually even
more general okay so the method of
proving this result yeah the constants
not quite sharp but so in the scalar
case this is just the kenshin and
equality of course the concern equality
is Elementary this this proof is
elementary actually more or less but
it's only because of some very clever
ideas due to on Chatterjee yes no no
actually I would rather not get into
that because it's already late in the
afternoon I've been talking for a long
time and doing another example would
take another 15 minutes so the same
applications that the last result on
tail bounce for the Rademacher series
this is an even sharper version of that
result so that's one way to think about
it you can prove those same tail bounds
using this detective I don't mean to be
dismissive of happy to talk with you
more on tomorrow maybe
just a different method of motivational
Sammis you know exactly but I mean I
didn't really motivate why you would
care about Rademacher series to begin
with but uh what can you do
alright so let's get started on this
proof so the first definition is one
that's familiar to probable is an
exchangeable pair so I'm going to be a
little bit sloppy about all of the stuff
because I don't really feel like the
rigor adds all that much so a pair of Z
Z prime of random variables is
exchangeable if the distribution of Z Z
prime is indistinguishable from the
distribution of Z prime Z so all right
these two random variables cannot be
distinguished from each other some sense
all right this is not to say that these
in two variables are independent the
marginal distribution of Z and the
marginal distribution of Z prime must be
the same in particular otherwise you'd
be able to tell them apart right but Z
and Z prime can be very closely
connected okay
it's just that averages and other
functions depending on these variables
don't change when you swap the variables
so basic definition and now we have
another definition which is rather less
familiar it's called a matrix tine pair
so a matrix tine pair is a special kind
of exchangeable random exchangeable pair
consisting of matrices so we're gonna
let X and X prime be an exchangeable
pair of hermitian random matrices
okay so each of these two members here
is a random matrix each one is hermitian
and they have the same distribution all
right then we say that X X prime is a
matrix tine pair if we have the
following reproducing property the
expectation of X minus X Prime
conditional on the sigma-algebra
generated by X is equal to Alpha X for
some alpha between 0 & 1
yikes so what does this mean in some
sense it tells us that the differences
between X and X prime reproduce X I'll
do an example in a minute that might
make this a little bit clearer but
frankly this definition has some amount
of magic in it and it's that magic that
makes everything work okay the key point
though is that if we fix X and then
average out over whatever randomness is
left in X prime we spit out a scaled
copy of X why would you believe that
such a thing is interesting or that are
u even exists well because there's an
example so the example that we're going
to use is a Rademacher series
it offers wanting if they're independent
offices if they're if they're
independent alphas one right so because
X and in particular it turns out X prime
would have to be equal to zero
I didn't mean of X prime must be equal
to zero but okay so the idea behind all
of this is that if we can construct good
matrix tine pairs we can establish
concentration and equalities floor acts
okay so you should think about someone
handing you X and it's your job to
produce the exchangeable counterpart X
Prime
and good in this context means that well
X prime had better have the same
distribution as X and X prime will also
need to be close to X so this means same
distribution this means close to alright
so let's do an example and somehow sense
this is the most important example which
is probably where all of this came from
the first place and that is our matrix
Rademacher series so in this case X is
the sum of epsilon K times a K and we're
going to construct X prime by picking a
term from X at random and getting rid of
it and then we have to put it back but
we'll replace it with a fresh copy of
the randomness in the Rademacher
variable so here we've got a uniformly
chosen index so we're picking one entry
from this sum to knock out and and
epsilon prime
an independent copy of Epsilon so these
are all fresh Rademacher variables okay
so we knock out the ice term from the
sum and we replace it by another copy
where we put in a fresh Rademacher okay
so you can see that this is not so
different from X because it only changed
one term and sometimes we don't even
change that and obviously these guys
have the same distribution because all
we've done is swapped out the randomness
in one of these Epsilon's for fresh
randomness okay so same distribution
close by all right so let's check this
condition find out what the scale factor
alpha is gonna be for this example oh
you're right so you can apparently
identify the scale factor by pure
thought so all right so what happens
well we have epsilon I minus epsilon I
prime times a I being the only term
remaining after we subtract and now
let's first average over the eyes
because we're not allowed to average
over these Epsilon's so this is the
expectation of the sum from I equals 1
to N of epsilon I minus epsilon i prime
times AI conditioned on Epsilon well now
this is easy we're not allowed to
average these guys out these guys have
mean 0 because they're independent from
this well all right
and we conclude that in fact this
reproduces the original series so it
turns out the so it turns out that this
is not the only example independent sums
more generally can be subjected to the
same treatment there other kinds of
examples you can do as well
found the difference type settings and
so forth but I want to focus on this
simple example here and you can see that
the key point is that we found an
exchangeable counterpart of the random
matrix that's very close by just by
knocking out one of the coordinates and
refreshing it alright we'll see I hope
why it is that this is a useful thing to
do in just a moment
and so this is the value of alpha okay
good
so the key result is that we can use
Styne pairs to compute expectations
alright so the result is a lemma known
as the method of exchangeable pairs and
the method of exchangeable pairs takes
as input a matrix tine pair and F a
matrix valued function and what it tells
us is that we can compute the
expectation of the form x times a
function of X so this takes X and spits
out a random matrix of a matrix of the
same size as 1 over 2 alpha times the
expectation of X minus X prime times f
of X minus f of X prime alright so if we
have an expectation of this form it can
be rewritten like this now stare at this
for a moment and try and understand why
it is if that could be a useful thing to
do
not with this method why don't I do the
proof first and then we'll talk about
why this is a an interesting argument
all right so here's the proof alpha
times the expectation of X FX can be
rewritten as the expectation of the
conditional expectation of X minus X
Prime conditional on X times f of X by
drawing the Alpha in here and then using
the definition of a matrix tine pair all
right now
this is constant once we know this Sigma
field so we can draw this inside the
conditional expectation and then combine
the conditional expectations so we'll
obtain the expectation of X minus X
prime times f of X so this is just usual
manipulations with conditional
expectations this is constant as a
function of X and then once this is
inside we use the tower property to get
rid of the conditioning ok all right now
we can do the same thing again
but now we're gonna use exchangeability
to switch X and X Prime here so this
expectation does not change if we swap
the identities of these two variables so
this is exchangeability
alright now we're gonna we're done
all right average these two things are
more finished okay good so here are two
examples so first of all what if f of X
fits out the identity matrix well that
tells us that this term is zero and so
we see that the expectation of X is
equal to zero so in other words a matrix
time pair always consists of 0 mean
random matrices all right so you can't
construct one of these otherwise the
other interesting example which is
really where this comes from the first
place of f of X is the identity map that
just spits out the matrix X in which
case this result tells us the
expectation of x squared is equal to the
expectation of X minus X prime squared
so times 1/2 to alpha u so in other
words this because is an alternative way
to compute variances alright and this is
really where these ideas come from so
this is a version of the Efrain stein
inequality familiar with that result
definite identity ok good now why would
this sort of thing be useful more
generally the answer is in the structure
of this expression and what we mean by a
good matrix tine pair so what property
does a good matrix tine pair have well
we've assumed that X and X prime are
close to each other right that's what we
hope to achieve so if X and X prime are
close this term is small and if X and X
prime are close and F is kind of
Lipschitz this guy is also small so we
can exploit
the fact that the hope at least said X
and X Prime are similar plus the
Lipschitz properties of of the map F and
we want to use those to bound
expectations or rewrite expectations of
this type and that's really why this is
a productive alright so next we've got
one more lemma that shows how this plays
out for these Rademacher the series this
is what we'll call the mean value trace
inequality so this says that if a and b
are hermitian matrices and P is a
natural number then the trace of a minus
B times a to the to P minus 1 minus B to
the to P minus 1 so this looks a lot
like that can be bounded as 1/2 times 2
P minus 1 times the trace of a minus B
squared times a to the 2 P minus 2 minus
B to the to P minus 2 okay so
this is going to allow us to take an
expression of this form and provide an
upper bound for it in terms of a
difference squared so this will be like
a variance term and this should be a
plus sign all right so I think in the
interest of time I'm not going to even
prove the scalar version of this for you
this is based on their permit
representation of a divided difference
and a result called the generalized
Cline inequality that allows you to lift
scalar inequalities to the matrix
setting this is really easy to prove
this is completely elementary even in
the matrix case there's nothing fancier
here than an eigenvalue decomposition
going on in the background so all right
now hmm yeah I mean you can extend this
to all real numbers without too much
work but there's more notation enough to
carry around so
I mean basically you're using the fact
that um those even powers or convex and
on the real line and so if you didn't
have an even power you need some
opposite values and some signals and
some other yes yeah all right now this
allows us these tools that I've
described allow us to prove a result for
matrix tine pairs that's called the
matrix Burkholder Davis Gundy and
equality and this is from the paper that
we wrote and it follows an argument that
was set out by Suraj Chatterjee so we'll
let X and X prime be a matrix tine pair
and we'll define a quantity called the
conditional variance Delta X which is 1
over 2 alpha times the conditional
expectation of X minus X prime squared
conditioned on X ok so you should think
about this like the norm of a gradient
so X minus X prime is an estimate for
how rapidly the random matrix is
changing near X you're squaring it and
so this is roughly a norm of a gradient
the Alpha is dividing out by the scale
so it's just a heuristic so if you're
familiar with things like log Sobel of
inequality is this is the norm of the
gradient that turns up there ok so the
result that we have is that the expected
trace of X to the 2 P to the 1 over 2 P
power is bounded by root 2 P minus 1
times the expectation of the trace of
Delta X to the P to the 1 over 2 P power
and that this is valid for natural
numbers P so it tells us that we can
compute high moments of a matrix tine
pair if we can compute slightly lower
moments of this conditional variance
okay and in the case of Rademacher
series this is going to be real easy to
compute so we'll do that in a few
minutes after we finish establishing
this result so this is really an
immediate consequence of these two
LaMotta that we have sitting here on the
board and then to prove the matrix
condition in equality we're just going
to combine that with the calculation
that I'm erasing at this very moment all
right
let's go so we're gonna define a the
quantity of interest e which is the
expected trace of X to the to P power
now we don't have anything in sight that
looks like x times f of X so we need to
find such a thing we're gonna do that
about peeling off a copy of X from this
power alright oh look we've got x times
the function of the random matrix and
this is exactly the form that we require
to apply the method of exchangeable
pairs so the method of exchangeable
pairs gives us 1 over 2 alpha times the
expectation of the trace of X minus X
prime times X to the to P minus 1 minus
X prime to the to P minus 1 so this is a
method of exchangeable pairs long mode
okay now this lemma here tells us
exactly how it can bound a quantity like
this this is a deterministic result
doesn't depend on the identity of the
matrices or anything like that so we'll
just apply this and we'll obtain the
expected trace of X minus X prime
squared times X to the 2p minus 2 plus X
prime to the 2p minus 2 and now we're
gonna have to put in this factor of 2
minus 1 and also this other factor of 2
that I left out from the lemma
ok so this is the mean value trace in
equality all right now we just have to
clean up we're done so the first thing
we're gonna do is notice that this term
here X minus X prime squared times this
power has the same distribution as X
minus X prime square
time's this power because of exchange
ability so each of the two terms in this
sum has the same average so we're just
going to get rid of one of them and
cancel the two here all right
so we got to P minus 1 over 2 alpha
times the expected trace of X minus X
prime squared times X to the 2 P minus 2
all right next we're going to go find a
copy of this conditional variance in
this expression so we'll pull the 2
alpha inside here and split the
expectation into the part conditional on
X and the part where we average out X
prime so this will give us 2 P minus 1
times the expected trace of Delta X
times X to the 2 P minus 2 so identify
Delta X all right now we're in apply
holders inequality for the trace and
then we're going to apply holders
inequality for the expectation and that
will give us 2 P minus 1 times the
expected trace of Delta X to the P to
the 1 over P times the expected trace of
x to the 2 P to the P minus 1 over P so
this is Helder twice all right what are
we found here see this guy on the board
anywhere just up at the top so we've got
an algebraic relation for the quantity
that we're interested in so we'll divide
through we'll raise to the appropriate
power and we'll conclude that e to the
so e is less than 2 P minus 1 to the P
times the expected trace of Delta X to
the P power
that's the result hmm did I make a
mistake the two alpha is now sitting
inside the Delta X is part of the
definition yeah all right any questions
on that calculation because this is
really uh exactly and the interesting
thing is that they can actually have a
lot to do with each other and that's
what makes this work of the fact that X
and X prime can be very very close all
right
oh good so we establish this result and
now we can prove the matrix kenshin
inequality by the way this is the most
elementary proof of this result that I
know
all right so so yep X is equal to the
sum of epsilon K times a K X prime
equals X minus epsilon I AI plus epsilon
I prime a I and so now we need to figure
out what Delta X's so Delta X is equal
to 1 over 2 alpha which is to say n over
2 times the expectation of X minus X
prime squared conditioned on X so this
is just this term here so again and over
2 times the expectation of epsilon I
minus epsilon I prime squared times a I
squared conditional on the randomness in
Epsilon first of all I urge over I so
sum from I equals 1/2 and once again I
forgotten the normalizing factor and now
all we have to do is average out over
the epsilon I prime but this can only
take two values zero or two squared each
occurs with equal probability so we have
1/2 times 4 is 2 it cancels the 2 here
and so when we complete this average we
see that obtain the sum from I equal 1
to N of AI squared which is also known
as the expectation of X
weird all right so here's the
calculation of the conditional variance
in this case it's very very easy and it
really just produces the variance of
this random matrix all right now all we
have to do is substitute this result
into the matrix B D G in equality and we
obtain the expectation of the trace of X
to the two P to the one over two P is
less than root two P minus one times the
expectation of x squared trace to the P
to the one over two P which is a result
of we required so in some sense this
matrix can't in an equality I realize I
didn't spend a lot of time motivating
this for you somehow is more powerful
than all the other results that we've
talked about and that if you don't care
about the constants you can drive almost
all of them by clever applications of
this by introducing bra democracy or
symmetrization process and then applying
this inequality so it really is very
powerful and this was something that was
really appreciated by Jill PCA
and it found its way into the work of
Ruud Olson in 1999 where he used this
technique to study the sample covariance
problem that I started out with in the
first lecture so the cool thing about
the method of exchangeable pairs is that
it provides a very elementary proof for
this result even the matrix setting and
it gives you a constant that's within a
factor of Rudie of optimal you can't
really improve this very much the other
really attractive thing about the method
of exchangeable pairs as opposed to some
of the other techniques we've talked
about is it extends from independent
sums to other kinds of random matrices
that are based on somewhat dependent
random variables and the reason is
because we can construct these matrix
time pairs somewhat more generally than
in the case of an independent
some so it's not exactly the same as a
martingale it doesn't have that
directional flavor that a martingale
does but you can prove found a
difference in equalities this way and
that's actually pretty straightforward
it's basically the argument that I just
showed you so I'm gonna stop now see if
there any more questions and then I'll
let y'all continue on to your happy hour
yeah you have the lower bound without
the factor over to P minus one and so
what that tells you is that the only
loss in this inequality is that square
root to P minus one any more or less you
have to do some extra work but it
certainly holds for the square actually
yeah no it's right this way to
assistances and equality any other
questions I just had a quick comment
about I really think this is a wonderful
thing that everyone should know
about Steinem just looping back to the
early part of the day
Stein developed wise ideas to prove the
James time history early it was all tied
up in his mind but uh if you'll see and
gels presentation was never a mention of
Independence that was never the
exponential is just a various in in run
around the kind you know Fourier met
that you used to prove central limit
theorems and exchange and large
deviations your songs just completed for
technology and so independence is not
needed you get by with dependence the
other point is that Joel's example I
mean is Rademacher very effectively here
because you can do all the calculations
in thirty minutes
the Rademacher just simple summer you
take out one make you strong did you
have one part of someone some night and
put in a new one but think more
generally you have some comment or
structure grab sites or some other comic
Turtles I'm sure some algebraic
structure where it's natural to take out
something and put in something else in a
random place that's why they go mad and
in fact these ideas will apply to all
kinds of other projects
Oh us me so the Chatterjee's paper
really is kind of miraculous he managed
the you know it took us 45 pages to do
this in the matrix setting and it's not
because of our arguments any harder it's
just that he was so much more economical
in his presentation you know in 15 pages
he's developed you know all of these
results in the scalar setting
exponential concentration polynomial
moment bounce and applied them to four
different examples involving spin
glasses and graph theory it's really a
yeah one of my emphasizes this
presentation here this entire argument
was envisioned by Mike's to know Lester
Mackey and he developed a the entire
version of this argument applied it to
matrices and developed this wonderful
proof of the non-commutative Kenshin and
equality all by himself he's I'm in the
statistics faculty at Stanford now so
his reputation preceded him and I think
that he's you know also someone who's
worth paying attention to
they've done great work on this problem
okay I was allotted one day let's thank
Joel again